of
we have we find the present
current practice in the Netherlands is balanced
and actually say
you don't need additional things
do both one side or the other
with with abortion
so no organism about that proposal
no no enthusiasm
I would say 1 bit with Hillary Clinton
abortion must be safe
legal and wear
Otherwise I SAY English yes
but safe legal
and rare yes
but if you would like to continue to strive for cancer
look this is this is
for women 1 of the most difficult
decisions in their lives
that women can make from scratch
they don't need anyone for that
you must also respect that decision
that has nothing to do with criminal law
this is for doctors
also 1 procedure
which is very difficult for them and which
they also do with the utmost care
they should not
be smeared with the idea
that they might do something
that falls under the criminal code
so the only thing we want to see changed
is that it
is removed from the criminal code
and just under care
this has concern
that has nothing to do with criminal law
that is the proposal
nothing changes in the procedures
nothing else changes in the rules
but you take away 1 lot of stress in women
and with the people in the medical profession
when you take it away from criminal justice and stop in the sun
yes it is in the book of criminal law
and the 5th paragraph of that also says
abortion
committed in abortion clinic and Dutch hospitals
are not punishable
so it is very clear that as 1 abortion clinic
1 abortion is committed up to 24 weeks
that this is not covered by criminal law
it does fall under criminal law
you cannot have 1 healthy in the Netherlands
fruit of 40 weeks of abortion
that is punishable
and there is also explicit
criminality in the criminal code
if you do it outside the hospital
and there is 1 extra heavy one
punishment if the woman dies